demande d'actions collectives contre
quatre géants de la transformation de
boeuf qui aurait gonflé artificiellement
les prix les entreprises ciblées son
cargo gb s theissen nationaux beef
packing qui contrôle 80 5% du marché du
boeuf au canada toute personne qui a
acheté du boeuf au québec depuis janvier
2015 et visées par la demande
d'autorisation vous le voyez les prix
ont augmenté de 25 à 53 % depuis 2000 15
pour certains types de boeuf avec nous
sylvie de bellefeuille avocate chez
option consommateurs demande reste de
l'action collective bonsoir madame de
bellefeuille bonsoir monsieur fillion
qu'est ce que vous reprochez
particulièrement ces entreprises
en fait ce qu'on reproche à ces
entreprises là c'est de s'être entendus
entre elles pour pouvoir fixer
artificiellement le prix en fait pour
mettre la pression sur le marché de
façon à faire gonfler artificiellement
le prix du boeuf que l'on achète alors
ça vise à la fois le boeuf qu'on peut
acheter à l'épicerie mme celui qu'on
peut acheter à la boucherie ou même dans
son restaurant et comment fait on pour
déterminer comme ça qu'on paie le boeuf
trop cher
mais c'est sûr que ça va devenir une
preuve qu'on va devoir faire de façon
plus et a fait quand on va se présenter
en cour donc il va y avoir des preuves
au niveau de l'expertisé qui va devoir
être déposé en temps utile ce qu on a
quand même comme éléments de preuve
c'est que il ya quand même eu des
demandes qui ont été faites semblable
aux états unis on a une demande en
action collective qui a été fait aussi
en colombie-britannique et même des
enquêtes aux états unis qui ont été qui
ont été faites alors il ya quand même
plusieurs éléments que nous portent à
croire la queue y aurait un problème sur
le marché mais est-ce qu'il ya quelque
part en amérique du nord un endroit où
on a prouvé qu'un cartel qu'il ya
collusion
mais au moment où on se parle on n'a pas
de mot on n'a pas de tribunal qui a pris
une décision là-dessus quand même une
des entreprises qui a réglé hors cour
dans le cadre de l'action collective
américaine
donc
oui c'est sûr que ce sans admission de
responsabilité mais quand même un âge
habituellement dans ce genre de dossier
et souvent aussi des ententes qui visait
la collaboration donc on va pouvoir
avoir des éléments des éléments de
preuve toutefois les avocats américains
pour avoir des éléments de preuve on
verra ce qui pourra sortir de tout ça
mais on a quand même bon espoir au moins
autant au stade où on est au moins
d'obtenir l'autorisation de faire
l'action collective depuis un an le prix
du boeuf a augmenté de 17% nous dit
statistique canada et quand on regarde
depuis 2015 on voit que sa voix jusqu'à
53 % pour le rôti de côte de boeuf 53 3%
de février 2015 à février 2022 quelle
est la part de croissance normale et la
part artificiel selon vous
ben là encore ça va être quelque chose
qui va devoir déterminer avec des
experts parce que quand même des jeux
qui se font avec l'inflation puis on se
le cachera pas la pandémie a quand même
eu un impact à bien des niveaux
maintenant la pandémie au dos large et
le cartel a légué est quand même remonte
à 2015 alors une partie de ce qui est
artificiel tout ça va devoir être
trouvée devant les tribunaux combien
vous demander
on n'a pas de chiffres et la demande au
moment où on se parle parce que
justement on n'a pas tous les chiffres à
portée de main l'idée dans le fonds de
secours ce qu'on demande dans le fond
c'est que l'on a les entreprises soient
condamnés à rembourser la partie
artificiellement gonflé donc tout ça va
devoir être faits à partir des propres
experts de marie et donc c'est des
millions de dollars qui pourrait être
obtenu
c'est ce qu'on souhaite effectivement on
parle de quand même de ses traits
l'argent on parle et au québec on parle
non seulement des consommateurs de boeuf
ou ceux qui l'ont acheté pour le
consommer mais quand on parle d'
acheteur de boeuf ça pu viser également
les entreprises comme votre boucher ou
autres l'ipsi qui achètent du boeuf pour
ensuite le revendre alors c'était quand
même un marché qui est énorme et donc on
parle de tous les québécois donc si
quelqu'un qui nous écoutent cachette du
boeuf et qui en a acheté depuis 2015
pourrait faire partie de l'action
collective si l'action collective est
autorisée c'est exact et donc on
pourrait s que est ce que quand on parle
de millions de dollars bon c'est une
chose des millions de dollars mais par
personne ce serait quelques dizaines de
dollars quelques centaines ça
ressemblera à quoi
y est trop tôt pour le savoir et surtout
trop tôt aussi pour voir de quelle dans
quelle direction va prendre la fin du
litige ans parce que en changeant de dos
et là bonjour d'abord commencé par
donner l'autorisation je ne pourrais y
avoir éventuellement un procès si on
obtient l'autorisation à travers tout ça
il ya des possibilités de règlement hors
cour dont les montants qu'ils vont
pouvoir être redistribuées sont
évidemment tributaire des différentes
étapes à franchir dans le dossier
parfait on va suivre ça de près et avec
intérêt votre demande d'actions
collectives madame de bellefeuille merci
d'avoir été avec nous c'est un plaisir